Great, so we know how to define classes and create instances. We don't know how
to do anything useful with them yet, so that's what we're going to learn next.
We're going to learn about attributes. If we want to do something more
interesting with our classes, we need to add attributes to them. And in Python,
we can do that very simply. We can use the object, followed by a dot, followed
by a name. This is the name of the attribute. And if we want to create a new
attribute, or update an old one, we can use assignment so we can assign that to
some value. What this does is it sets the value associated with the attribute
name, for the object here, to be whatever this expression evaluates to. So, let
me show you an example. So here, we've created an instance of the Restaurant
class. It has no attributes yet, but we can add one. Using the syntax, we're
adding an attribute name and giving it the value of the string, McDowell's
Burger Emporium. And now, we can use that attribute. Note that adding an
attribute doesn't create a new object, it just adds attributes to that object.
So, we already had our Restaurant object. That was created when we did this. We
had a new instance of it, and we labeled it McDowell's. Now, we've taken that
object and we've added an attribute name to it, and we've given it some value.
Notice that if we create a new Restaurant instance, this is creating a new
object and we're assigning it to the name chez_bananas. So, the chez_bananas
object does not have a name attribute. If we try to look for it, we'll get an
error. We get an AttributeError that says, this Restaurant object has no
attribute name, name. We can add one. Now, we've added a name attribute to Chez
Bananas, add this long string. That didn't change the name of McDowell's.
They're separate objects with separate names. We can of course add other
attributes, so we can add say, an owner. Add another attribute, and we will also
add a chef attributes. These didn't change anything about the object that Chez
Bananas points to. Just to confirm, Chez Bananas still has no chef. Just like
any other name, we can change what a name refers to, so we can change what an
attribute refers to. We'll do that just within assignment. So, suppose Chef
Quesy was fired. We have a new chef at McDowell's, we have Chef Hurl. And
that'll change the value associated with this name. Now, the chef attribute
points to the string, Chef Hurl. Sounds very yummy to me. We can define
functions that work on our objects. Let's define a display_restaurant function,
and it's going to take a restaurant as input, and all it will do is print the
name of the restaurant. So, let's try that. We'll call the display restaurant
passing in the object McDowell's refers to, which has the name McDowell's
something or other. We can do the same thing with the object Chez Bananas refers
to.